aujourd'hui va être le jour le plus incroyable
de ta vie ton journal tu dis la
même chose tous les jours André et chaque jour
tu as tort d'
essayer de te cacher petit homme tu veux mon
portefeuille je veux ton arme tu crois ce
clown
gentil de te bousculer  ce qui vient de se passer, c'est
le film que nous allons faire,
tout a été mis en scène ouais, tous les
acteurs, ma réponse est non, ce son
ne vous mérite pas, vous m'entendez. Kevin
Darnell Hart est un trésor national,
je pense que je le vois.
qu'est-ce que c'est oh non non faisons en sorte que
ta marque arrête là
un gars essayait de me tuer
film d'action en direct Nous améliorons toutes
les scènes d'action
J'essaie littéralement de nous assassiner Kevin
ce que tu as été ici pas  mon sang est-ce que ça
semble faux ow
non non non non attends regarde il y a un
photographe regarde regarde ta photo
je ne peux pas me promener avec des vêtements ensanglantés
c'est un homme juste là qui est ce mon
père il est parti depuis longtemps il a sauté
sur le chemin de  un couteau destiné à Richard
Pryor oh mon Dieu pourquoi quelqu'un voudrait-il
tuer Richard Pryor il n'y
a qu'un seul homme qui peut vous aider à
trouver qui est derrière tout ça bonjour la science
n'a pas de sollicitation partez ouais non nous ne l'avons pas fait
nous n'avons pas vu de signe il y a  aucun signe que nous
ne l'avons pas pris, c'est
moi, c'est Kevin Hart,
comment aimez-vous votre thé,
je vous mets mal à l'aise, je suis tellement
nerveux pour vous monsieur parce que vous avez
du thé très chaud et c'est juste au-dessus de
vos fesses, c'est un  moment de la bande-annonce